que nadie se salte la pila para las
vacunas con esa advertencia la
organización mundial de la salud instó a
los países de mayores recursos a dejar
de firmar acuerdos directos con las
productoras y permitir que naciones de
menores ingresos accedan a las
inmunizaciones mediante el mecanismo
solidario cobats wing voz en medellin
cancán estamos viendo a países de
ingresos altos y medios que son parte de
kóvacs a alcanzar acuerdos bilaterales
adicionales potencialmente esto eleva el
precio para todos y significa que las
personas de mayor riesgo en los países
más pobres y vulnerables no obtienen la
vacuna el nacionalismo de la vacuna nos
hiere a todos y es contraproducente old
and self déficit según la o ms 42 países
han iniciado la vacunación 36 altos
recursos y 6 de medios mientras que el
proceso no ha comenzado en ninguna
nación pobre por eso el organismo instó
a quienes tienen más dosis de las
necesarias a donarlas al programa cobats
un llamado que contrasta con el anuncio
de la unión europea que duplicó su
pedido a facer variante que así pasará
de 300 a 600 millones de dosis es decir
casi la mitad de la producción
tal de esa alianza para 2021 de momento
es la única en circulación en el bloque
a la espera de la distribución de las
180 millones de dosis adquiridas a
moderna which is you is right round
estas dos vacunas autorizadas ya hemos
asegurado una cantidad de dosis
necesaria para vacunar a 380 millones de
europeos esto es más del 80 por ciento
de la población europea modern age
percent of the orphans
collection la contracara es áfrica donde
los altos precios y las condiciones de
conservación a temperaturas bajas han
supuesto problemas para adquirir las
vacunas una situación que aprovecha
china para expandir su influencia en el
continente prometiendo entregar su
vacuna a las naciones de menores
recursos